the Supreme Court traditionally rules on
party's eligibility to take part in
elections this year there's intense
interest in that ruling that's because
Greek's National Party is the vehicle of
this man Elias cassidiaris former
spokesman for Golden Dawn Greece's
neo-fascist party condemned as a
criminal organization in 2020 its
leading figures sentenced to 14 years in
jail
says he can't constitutionally be
prevented from running
the Greek Constitution requires an
irrevocable criminal conviction to Bar
any citizen from elected office so a
person has to be found guilty on appeal
to the Supreme Court here we have the
unique situation of a person with the
first conviction being stripped off the
right to office while he still enjoys
the presumption of innocence
Greece's Constitution is very liberal it
makes it essentially impossible to
disqualify parties that's why the ruling
new democracy conservatives focused on
disqualifying cassidialis and his
colleagues as individuals the government
has passed three legal amendments in the
last two years aimed at keeping former
Golden Dawn members out of parliament
the Amendments broadly say that certain
types of convicted felons may not
participate in or lead political parties
or be ineffective control principal
parties that they've put straw men
nominally in charge of but opponents of
these amendments both in the Judiciary
and in Parliament have said that they
are potentially unconstitutional
constitutional lawyer Janice is among
those who believe the government has
pushed the Constitution to its limit but
even he says the government did the
right thing albeit in a legally clumsy
way
the racist and Nazi speech which is
prohibited both in my country and in
Europe
and it is
accepted that it is
by which of the Constitution
prohibited
cannot be
illicit and legal
transformed into electoral speech and
electoral activity
another right-wing party has been
approved to run its leader is not a
felon demonstrating how difficult it may
be for Greece to bypass Europe's
political swing to the right John
saropoulos Al Jazeera Athens